this is the mayor of Chicago getting
brutally destroyed by a local reporter
to her face I never thought in my life
that I would ever see the city of
Chicago brought down so low as you have
managed to bring it down
shame on you I hope that you realize
what damage you have done to the city I
hope that after today's city council
meeting you will pack your suitcase
and get that out of my city you are a
pandemic 800 people were killed in
Chicago in 2021 under her watch 700 were
clapped last year in fact there were
less American deaths in the Afghanistan
war at its peak compared to Chicago of
last year and this year 70 people have
already been killed and guess what Lori
leifa recently became the first Chicago
mayor to lose re-election in 40 years